però con degli amici bene altre una
serata per te carcino birra sambughè
kotka ciao ragazzi bentornato in una
puntata di vita buttata errata
tantissimo che non ne giravamo una
finalmente arrivato il momento di riina
augurare questo format un ospite
speciale ma prima di presentarvelo
sappiate che il tema di oggi è
ubriacature il ritorno ci sono ospiti
speciali che portano con sé puntate e
temi speciali non è un congiunto infatti
staremo a m distanza non è manco un
amico infatti pensato anche di aumentare
più la distanza e parla direttamente in
un campo di calcio sto parlando di
claudio di biagio come andiamo cercando
le cadute leggermente più si è chiaro e
palese della gara ho fatto sono un po
più si sappia che questo qui è il nostro
verso incontro sulle brega tour e morali
sono pensati che non è perché non sa
deve fregatura è un tema al quale
teniamo tantissimo per sé lo avevamo
preparato un sacco di tempo fa ma non
possiamo farlo con altre persone se non
con te ma perché proprio perché ti
appartiene
la cosa che vorrei dire però che
l'avvocato mio non ha detto no o claudio
non potete fare ubriacature quindi siete
liberissimi di farlo pochi ve pare però
sono molto felice è tornato dice io sono
contento che tu sei qui anche perché ha
centrato mai subito raccontato di un
piccolo anello le si sa è legato alle
brigate ma ne parleremo più avanza io
direi come al solito di ascoltare gli
audio che mi sono arrivati su facebook
c'è un upgrade che lo tiene nascosto
ecco perché lì sempre a bocca aperta
[Risate]
partiamo prendiamo intero con il ragazzo
era pro polizia della nostra conoscenza
agli mi fa dai ti porto a mangiare sushi
ma guarda realtà me non piace tanto no
no dai
diamo erano a tavola per farmi andar giù
quello che mangiamo che a me ovviamente
non piaceva ho bevuto non so quanto vino
che poi la sera in albergo
ho vomitato tutto ma proprio questa una
scena pietosa c'è basta mura tanto
insieme
davanti a lui ho sbloccato anche l'anima
e intanto io ho detto ti amo ma che
figura di merda o sbucando cosa faccio
immagino questo ritaglio di amore che
sia partita non immaginati che schifo
che ci sono persone che le prime sere
per fare colpo bocca roma ci sono
persone ma queste persone dove si sono
combattute vivo nel mondo le persone se
che per fare colpo al primo secondo
terzo appuntamento dipende quando viene
abbattuta diciamo la distanza la paura
di quello che sta per dire perché
proprio persone che cercano di fondo e
resistono resistono alla fine ma sarà
tutto bippato perché però la mia faccia
spero che faccia segrate questo
smarrimento
guarda che quest'acqua è fortunata in
confronto è il concetto di stappare che
è importante questi gli appuntamenti
esatto grazie a questo era un benvenuto
siamo pronti alla partita vai ciao
cuccia ospite ciao la vinaccia gian
marco ciao enrico ciao buldo ciao a
tutti allora i nomi sono ormai ubriacata
perché sono astemia proprio il sapore
dell'alcol non mi piace per noi ha una
volta sono andata a casa dei miei amici
e mi hanno offerto un cioccolatino
sottomarca ci tengo a precisare quelle
tipo da discount
mi accorgo che l'interno c'era delle
cuore soltanto che non potevo sputarlo
questi davanti a tutti quindi ho dovuto
ingoiare quel mix di cioccolato il
liquore pessimo circa 5 minuti ha
cominciato a girarmi sentivo le voci in
lontananza armi sono praticamente
obbligato contornati da fare per gli
spot in rete
che la mamma di una mia amica si è
ubriacata cioccolatini ma ne ha mangiati
tipo 35 lo chiedo a lei cosa che ha
fatto questa nel 1640 che non poteva
sputare il cioccolatino
non posso sputare il suo fratello al
mestiere e preparate detto da claudio
che appena in una casa ti dice dov'è il
bagno che devo kakà ciao vi erano solo
massimiliano darò mai 86 anni
premetto che io praticamente non bevo
quasi mai
l'unica volta che ho bevuto tanto
avevamo un pranzo in un agriturismo nel
viterbese
abbiamo bevuto in 46 litri di vino in
modo talmente ubriaco mi sono alzato per
andare al bagno non sono tornato mi
voglio prendere i miei amici mi ero
addormentato in piedi mentre faceva pipì
e con la testa appoggiata al muro sono
stato in quella posizione per 30 minuti
ciao grazie ma io mi chiedo e vi chiedo
di 36 anni perché dare tutte queste
informazioni date questo il racconto che
devi fare cioè non è tipo salvato
bambino io cercherò in tutti i modi di
mantenere l'anonimato caro max dopo un
po si son detti ma questo quadro
mezz'ora io penso che potrei
dimenticarmi una persona per mezz'ora va
dimenticato sessione per anni ha tante
cene non so se è un problema solo mio
marito e cioè sonno a meno blocco facile
facile quindi se mi prende la blocco io
cosa faccio la cosa pazzesca
vado al bagno e mi poggio al muro e
dormo due minuti
esco come se avessi esco fuori che sto a
mille wow
scusa ma tu ti metti un timer
prospettive qualcuno bussi il mio corpo
nei bagni dei ristoranti che peraltro
adoro diciamo un alimentazione
certo dove vivere io vado al ristorante
entro dentro al bagno mi metto due
minuti tutto così in piedi non ci credo
che il giudice che tu sei una gialla di
bacilli qualche tipo tariffato colpisce
due pareti ciavoliello a questa voce
perché in realtà ieri ero ubriaca a
parlare una volta ho bevuto alle 8 di
mattina che chi lo sa e dentifricio e
roma ancora ubriaca dalla sera prima e
cercavo di riprendermi quindi ho
mischiato al proprio routine giornaliera
mano con le dopo la notte con fusion ha
fatto una crasi tra due cose che non
hanno senso insieme in realtà fortunata
perché avrebbe potuto che ne so unire le
gira sull e dentifricio credo crei uno
squarcio spazio temporale direttamente
nel 1600 dove la nostra amica a tanto
maggio su quella di neri non può fare a
meno che le non può proprio fare niente
una volta da piccolo ha preso questa
balla incredibile di vino rosso e quella
notte allo scoccare mezzanotte sarebbe
stato il compleanno di mia mamma
edinson arrivata a casa piena di vino
rosso fino all'ultimo capello è un
aspettava sveglia che s'era tipo
mezzanotte e mezza luna quindi arrivo a
casa la trovi soggiorno le da un
abbraccione e dico tanti auguri mamma in
quel momento mi sento il vomito che
inizia per salirvi sopra avola va quindi
corro cerchiamo di far finta di niente
ma comunque in prati cometario erano
gambe e per il corridoio già inizio
unità re tutto senza uscire ad arrivare
al cesso non certo tutta lascia in
corridoio però io ubriaca quindi a quel
punto secco il problema ancora
risolvibile torno torno torno sul tono
in corridoio e il suo pulire con la
carta igienica solo in corridoio che
pulisco vomito mentre vomito con la
carta igienica quindi praticamente il
mento pulisco mi vomito sulle mie stesse
mani
arriva e mia madre mi guarda e dice
solamente che compleanno marchi se ne va
usato sporco allora piuttosto che star
male di stomaco preferisco farmi uscire
delle ulcere
io ho capito qual è l'immagine di questo
messaggio che ci è arrivato sapete
quella candy camera in cui tu ti fai la
doccia e ti rimettono stagione mentre
guidava e pubblicare racconti più papa a
dominare chiama perché in questi casi io
vorrei citare infatti matteo bruno la
tecnica homeless
se stai male e torni a casa dormi in
giardino dohrn importuni davanti per un
po immagina così rivolto a lungo è
commissariato e sei tranquillo che
qualcuno le mura dipende quella che era
pensato molto importante blog ciao
matteo salute e alla come come diventato
secondo te durante debole integrante
materia così 14 amici in un campeggio la
vieste e la notte di ferragosto e
spiaggia c'era
chiesto che la norma brega dove la mia e
quella del hubble e complicarmi ma
l'unica bottiglia di vino che avevo
trovato era un vino rosso caldissimo
appoggiato sul motore il rigorismo
quindi era praticamente bollente mi
sapete forse quasi tutta la bottiglia mi
sono addormentato potreste google dino
tranne te notte avevo voglia pazzesca di
fare la pipì mi sono avvicinato dalla
spiaggia verso il recinto del campeggio
per fare tre mesi ci hanno messo un
quarto d'ora
[Musica]
come fate a fare queste cose io mi
domando come si fa claudio ha fatto la
sua andato italiana ma chissà che poiché
gli addetti al cervello ma poi ho mai
chiesto ma che evento è bellissimo ciao
ciao ospite
volevo raccontarti di questa mia
esperienza io e la mia migliore amica
abbiamo l'abitudine di prendere sempre
tutti i giovedì sera una bottiglia di
moscato andare in questo pub che c'è
dietro casa nostra a piedi mentre
andiamo vediamo questa politica quella
sera aveva deciso di prendere una
bottiglia di moscato a testa è una birra
testa sui libri che diciamo che quali
sembrate lì eravamo già belle brilla una
volta arrivate lì abbiamo deciso di
prendere un altro drink certo punto
faceva anche freddo la mia pancia inizia
pronto l'area dovevo pagare tanti
dobbiamo andare assolutamente dobbiamo
andare a vivere tranquillamente stima
aspettano trovi salutare che saluta
passa mezz'ora ce ne andiamo e mi dice
siena perché avere tutta questa fretta
devo pagare non ce la facevo più
l'ho detto fammi un attimo da palo mi
sono infilata in una via o calato e
desolata pensare a che cosa più grave
a mano che schifo ma di che stiamo
perché l'ha fatto una penna vanta un
campeggio e questo è il papa al bagno
del padre quando sei ubriaco un'idea
stupida ti sembra la genialata del
secolo cioè tu dici che l'ha fatto a
poche pensa che bello secca possiamo
almeno noi non utilizzare il termine
cagare c'è un nemico che utilizza ora è
scritto è un mio carissimo amico
antonello che saluto che utilizza per il
matinée per determinare il momento in
cui è quasi troppo tardi
pronti pallone in pericolo è chiaro
quanto è successo io ho un'immagine
invece che un mio amico il nome mirko
quando devi andare in bagno ma continui
comunque a trattenere albertelli sono
tutte le tenere quindi stai temperando
ti faccio il gesto e quindi se si sa se
si peraltro ammetto che una cosa che mi
piace fare zio che ne sente il russo
verso piazza venezia il primato di lusso
come una casa male carabinieri di milano
avevamo veramente misha dopo siamo
bevuti vicine che mostra gaza techno
andavano antico quasi il canto la rotta
elencato segue da vicino il tempo di
borsa ma zitto che mi sento un calcio
più manico e dopo travica conta 5
iniziata come chiede che la piazza
venezia in trovi fisico
c'è il sacco del consumo signore
innanzitutto il calcio in cui credo
abbia dato un poliziotto un canale le
forze dell'ordine lo è preposta a tareq
al 5 dalle famosissime commissariato da
trilussa in 30 secondi a piazza venezia
che insomma non ci sentono 30 secondi
diciamolo per chi non è di roma a piazza
venezia ci mette un bel po
siamo felici che però stia bene c'è
anche te ospite eravamo compleanno di
una nostra amica ricordo e niente tutto
ad un tratto finiscono le sigarette
decidiamo quindi io mio amico di andare
giù a prenderle ci siamo ritrovati in
stazione centrale e siamo finiti una
settimana in liguria a che punto ci
credevo una morti come possibile
settimane e tanto però magari queste
zone sono ricche di famiglia perché del
lavoro di stu però potrebbe anche essere
quella settimana dove tutti i ciclisti
casi e poi doni da licenziato e lo
scienziato disconosciuto però la ragazza
ha detto con una el per officina liguria
ospiti ovviamente uno degli aneddoti che
mi ricordo più facilmente è stata una
volta che abbiamo convinto uno dei
nostri amici a presentarci la ragazza
con cui si stava frequentando siamo
andati a questo locale a piazza trilussa
dove lei lavorava qui ha detto mi
raccomando però fatemi fare una bella
figura
ottocento ci mancherebbe matera volta
dentro lì comincia ad ordinare bicchieri
di birra shottini cocktail la volontà 1
praticamente del tavolino pieno a un
certo punto non so come è successo si è
ribaltato il tavolino e rovesciando
tutto quindi cocktail che di bicchieri
vuoti si è spaccato tutto praticamente
dura venire la ragazza vuoi dire tutto e
niente per stata l'ultima volta che loro
due si sono visti ancora ci odia per
questo ciao ciao ciao
lo so lo so potremmo dirlo proprio ai
unisono meglio così perché se una dopo
la prima volta succederà del genere e
poi non avete più ma cosa vuoi
ma cosa vuoi devo convintissimo che sono
d'accordo se io ti voglio far conoscere
la mia ragazza ma di vere che però
voglio far conoscere mentre sta
lavorando ci lavorava quando che certo
punto lei dettaglio lavorava al pub del
reato dopo i tubi di russa dove c'è la
caserma piazza
la pace armi fa in preda a una sbronza
colossale abbiamo avuto con dei miei
amici una idea molto intelligente vado è
rubare
anzi non rubati salvare da giardino era
rinchiuso in un cortile di una casa lo
storytelling e furto
abbiamo organizzato questo rapimento
scavalcava quindi parlando da giardino e
siamo scappati tutti quanti però poi ci
è venuto un senso di colpa è liberato da
bim il resto in un bosco si sa se sia
attorno ai ragazzi non c'è niente
dilettanti questa legge è simpatico per
chi sono quando cos'è che trovi così
ilare la faccia del male che è sempre
stata per tutta la storia questa e tu
hai detto volevo lo sappiamo noi venduto
da sudare un po in mezzo al bosco da
tutta la notte
ripresi
[Risate]
credo che stiamo esagerando non so
perché problema così bambino che viene
rapito invece salvato ok ci siamo no non
c'è guarda 3 2 1 ma quindi la prima
volta saranno i messaggi con seconda
parte si solo l'età piazza ecco ma
questa gag azzecca piffer su ping pong
basta
[Applauso]
c'è quindi imparato a stare zitto una
volta mi sono ragazzo una volta mi stavo
facendo la doccia cento che avevo queste
le schegge conficcata nel cranio che mi
sono state tolte con la pinzetta
riflessioni mi sono ricordata che è
completamente ubriaca
avevo preso a testate la palla usa i
propri giorni prima completamente
ubriaca avevo preso a testate la palma
era per via di una delusione d'amore
quindi suppongo di essere meno
parzialmente giustificato motivo che mi
ha lasciato porsi in una zona la testata
come lavora così indietro non è sì
maggiori scena da film ti appoggi alla
mamma di schema scivoli perdere
il problema è stupida io e teme di roma
dall'alto di notte che va poi quasi
allarghi cioè questo nome dal giardino è
una parola che questa festa con gli
amici ha certo punto collasso sono
specie di letto che vedo di aver visto
un attività che si avvicinasse a me sia
distesa sul letto e mi sembrava
orgogliosa ho cercato di palpeggiarla
iniziato dal basso ventre e ho detto ben
aia fisica per la ragazza però ha
sondato che in basso è scoperto la
tecnica e merita quale la terribilità
secondo questo nostro amico il caso dai
tenenti piglierebbe male forse invece la
volta buona per scoprire delle cose anzi
io lo prenderei come un banco di prova
lo prenderesti punto tu non hai un nuovo
vento di ubriacatura per quanto ti
riguarda
sono andato alla mia madre ho bevuto
troppo e ti parlerò in mezzo appena
finita la ce ne sono andato per cosa più
noiosa vecchio allora io ho effettuato
un upgrade
proprio in questo format io ho
raccontato insomma possono vedere le
altre puntate me scrive vorrei ripagare
buon flashback tante facce delle puntate
precedenti di claudio di biagio ubriaco
io per esempio ho avuto black out
raccontaci in cieli pure tu primo punto
unite no considera che io ero vestito da
chirichetto e andiamo avanti
hanno approfittato della mia bocca ho
fatto la cacca nel parco
non sono tornato a casa col costume ecco
quello era il mio modo per reagire
all'alcol l'ubriacatura macho ma non so
se l'età la quarantena ha cambiato tutto
inesatto ecco ero in quarantena e la
prima volta anche io ho vomitato
tantissimo fiumi a casa ero con la mia
ragazza che porella stava tipo a tenere
la testa così è stato orribile perché io
non avevo mai provato questo tipo di
sensazione come se qualcosa entrasse di
forza dentro e mesi sei casali sa tutto
fuori quindi io ho proprio bisogno di
dirvi aspettatevi di tutto dalle
ubriacature non siate confidenti nella
vostra
mi sa bene anche di tutto bevete
responsabilmente
perché altrimenti in quanto più brigate
può succedere di tutto
a volte è divertente bambini a volte non
lo è dietro l'angolo c'è tutto c'è la
pipì cerca del vomito
ci sono dei nani da giardino ci sono due
ragazzi che faranno bp nelle oasi dei
commissariati amici non vi ubriacate se
poi non sapete come reagire alla cattura
ma allo stesso tempo considerate che non
potete avere la piena consapevolezza di
come reagirete questo è molto importante
bimbi adesso andato a dormire e non
mettetevi alla guida ingeniere grazie
mille claudio comunque per aver preso
parte a questo video 6 prezioso grazie
mille a tutte le persone che hanno
condiviso nero commenti fateci sapere
quali sono le vostre storie legate del
bric a tours e come sempre iscriviti a
questo canale metteteci un bel pollice
su per il anche a claudio che ha
espresso io non lo credo che la
curiosità niente ci vediamo domenica con
la puntata di lucia buttata ciao
ma siete questo credo ancora